دلتا اندس 40 الف كيلو متر مربع من الارض
تتنازعها مياه نهر اندس العذبه ومياه بحر
العرب المالحه
تداخل المياه انعكس على وجوه الناس هنا
نرمي الشبكه صباحا ونجمعه بعد دقائق وكما
ترى دائما نجد اسماكا بعضها نهريه والاخرى
بحريه هذه الفتره جيده جدا لعملنا
نركز صيدنا على المواقع التي تختلط فيها
المياه العذبه بالمالحه حيث تكثر الاسماك
ويسهل صيدها
مع تداخل المياه تنوعت كثيرا الحياه
البريه في منطقه الدلتا
والى ساحل الدلتا مع البحر الممتد اكثر من
200 كيلو متر تصل اتباعا قوارب الصيد
المحمله بمختلف الاسماك
لا ينفقوا الصيادون هنا يتحدثون عن مدى
انتعاش حياتهم مع وفره الاسماك في دلتا
نهر اندس هذه المياه التي اختلط العذب
منها بالمالح الواصل من بحر العرب اضرت في
الوقت نفسه بالاراضي الزراعيه
مع تمدد البحر الى عمق ثمانيه كيلومترات
تاثرت خصوبه الاراضي بمنطقه كيتي بندر في
دلتا انداس فاضطر المزارعون الى البحث عن
بدائل
لا توجد مهنه واضحه حاليا لاي منا انا
اطبخ وابيع الطعام للصيادين وشقيق زوجي
يصلحان قوارب الصيد القديمه
وسيطر ماء البحر المالح على معظم اراضيها
المنخفضه فتضررت وذلك بسبب استغلال
الانسان خلال عقود للمياه العذبه قبل
وصولها الى دلتا وتحديدا بناء السدود على
نهر انداس وتشييد قناطر لاغراض الري
المخرج الوحيد من الوضع البيئي المعقد
لمنطقه دلتا انداس تمثل في زراعه اشجار
المانجروف او الايكه الساحليه التي توفر
ما يشبه المحاضنه للاسماك ويمكن ان
يستخدمها الانسان كحطب عبد الرحمن مطر
الجزيره اقليم السند